>> IDAHO 2000 MILES FROM THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BUT THE STATE IS
SEEING A SPIKE IN SENTINEL
OVERDOSES WITH THE DRUG TRAFFIC
IN THE REGION COMING FROM
MEXICO.
JILLIAN: LAWRENCE JONES GOT A
FIRSTHAND LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING
ON.
>> EVERY STATE IS A BORDER STATE
BECAUSE DRUGS THAT ARE COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY ARE AFFECTING
EVERYONE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAD TO SAY.
>> GOING INTO THIS AREA IT LOOKS
NICE AND CALM.
I GUARANTEE CARTEL MEMBERS IN
THIS AREA WE ARE GOING TO.
>> TO CALIFORNIA.
>> DRUGS COMING THIS WAY?
>> GOING TO EVERYONE -
>> EVERYTHING COMING ACROSS IT.
>> THAT SENTINEL COMING INTO
IDAHO.
>> IT IS GETTING WORSE BECAUSE
IT IS GETTING TO BE MORE
ABUNDANT AND CHEAPER.
>> 90,000 AMERICANS DIED OF DRUG
OVERDOSES.
THOSE DRUGS COME FROM ONE PLACE
SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
>> Reporter: SEVERAL OVERDOSE
DEATHS AND HOMICIDE.
IT WAS A FENTANYL DRUG DEAL
HAPPENING HUNDRED YARDS FROM THE
FRONT, HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO LOST
CHILDREN, LOST FATHERS, LOST
MOTHERS.
PEOPLE MANUFACTURING THIS
FENTANYL THAT ARE SELLING IT
ABSOLUTELY KNOW THAT IT KILLS
PEOPLE.
>> 40% OF EVERY PILL IS A LETHAL
DOSE.
>> IT IS ENOUGH TO KILL YOU.
TWO OFFICERS WHO FIND THIS INTO
JAIL WORKING ON THE GUY’S WALLET
AND BOTH MEN WENT TO THE GROUND.
THOSE ARE AIRBORNE PARTICLES.
EVERY DAY.
>> THIS IS WHERE YOUR OPERATIONS
HAPPEN.
TALK ABOUT HOW RISKY IT IS.
>> EVERY MINUTE OF EVERY DAY.
>> Reporter: DESIGNATED WALL, TO
DEFEND THE COUNTRY, NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
SAYING THIS IS A CRISIS AND WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS.
>> THE LETTER WENT OUT LAST
WEEK.
>> I MET MISTER TRUMP TWICE,
MEETING WITH HIM ON THESE
ISSUES.
THIS ADMINISTRATION, WE HAVE
NONE OF THAT.
THERE IS NO TABLE AND NO
PROBLEM.
>> IT IS REACTIONARY.
>> LET’S PUT A BAND-AID HERE.
>> NOT SOMETHING WE CAN ARREST.
TO DEAL WITH THE SUPPLY SIDE.
>> ARE WE LOSING THE WAR RIGHT
NOW.
>> LAW ENFORCEMENT IS IN THE
BATTLE TO THE END BUT AMERICA IS
LOSING THE BATTLE.
WE ARE LOSING THIS WAR AT THE
BORDER.
WE ARE LOSING THIS WAR IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> THE IMPACTFUL PEACE BUT
LOOKING ALL THE CARS COMING
ATTACKS COMING.
THEY HAVE BAD STUFF AND THAT IS
SHOCKING TO ME.
>> 40% OF DRUGS THEY ARE TAKING
ARE KNOWN TO HAVE FENTANYL IN
IT.
THESE ARE KIDS TRYING TO GO TO
PARTIES AND MIGHT WANT TO
EXPERIMENT BUT THAT EXPERIMENT
COULD KILL THEM AND THEY DON’T
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TAKING.
THE MOST TELLING PART OF THIS
PIECE SAYING WE CANNOT POLICE
ARE WAY OUT OF IT.
UNTIL THEY STOP THE PIPELINE
WHICH IS THE BORDER THERE IS NOT
GOING TO BE ANY TYPE OF
COMPROMISE ON THIS ISSUE.
>> THE WE ARE NOT INVITED TO THE
TABLE, THERE IS NO TABLE.
>> THEY SAY THIS IS ABOUT